seguramente no es la bienvenida que el
mejor tenista del mundo esperaba en
network este es el auto en el que se
cree novak djokovic entró al hotel en el
que ahora espera que se resuelva su
situación no le el número uno del tenis
apeló a la cancelación de su visa según
las autoridades el balcánico solicitó un
visado que no permita acogerse al tipo
de exención médica que le otorgaron las
autoridades del estado de victoria y que
le iba a permitir defender su título en
el abierto de australia pese a no haber
revelado su estado de vacunación en el
pasado djokovic ha expresado rechazo a
esta inyección y esa exención médica que
le otorgaron desató toda una polémica la
última reacción llegó por parte del
español rafael nadal que también
persigue su título de gran slam número
21 hacen acá
y
pienso que si lo hubiera querido estaría
aquí jugando en australia sin problema
el toma sus propias decisiones y todo el
mundo es libre de tomar sus propias
decisiones pero luego hay consecuencias
claro no me gusta lo que está pasando de
alguna manera lo lamento por él
el propio presidente de serbia
aleksandar vucic habló con djokovic por
vía telefónica y denunció que el tenista
estaba siendo acosado por su trato en
australia
[Música]
a las afueras del hotel en donde
permanece el djokovic conocido por
albergar a solicitantes de asilo y
refugiados bajo tratamiento médico se
han concentrado ya varios de sus
seguidores
y me siento triste siento que perdí
parte del corazón por djokovic djokovic
es mi hijo
djokovic podría enfrentarse a una
prohibición de tres años para aplicar a
visas en australia en caso de que se
demuestre que entregó información falsa
eso parece que se definirá el lunes de
la próxima semana en audiencia y ya con
el comienzo del torneo muy cerca el 17
de enero